[Music]
there we go you know I was actually
thinking about something that I want to
talk about it's not my hopes and dreams
kind of the movies that inspired me like
but I got into filmmaking know things
like Star Wars and you know video games
and Indiana Jones and Independence Day
and all that good stuff I was like you
know I'll work hard that's a filmmaker
and someday maybe I'll get to make the
next Star Wars maybe I'll get to make
the next Indiana Jones lifeline came out
last week and we were wrapping it up a
few weeks ago and as I was working on it
I realized that this love of franchise
films this dream of making you know
another Star Wars or making a video game
movie it's not gonna happen and it's not
that no one's ever gonna let me make a
franchise movie it's because there's so
much money riding on the line of
franchise films now but they're never
going to let anyone have a creative
voice in them any more franchise films
are big business because it's something
that you can bank on over and over
that's what the producers thing and so
they're not going to let anyone mess
with the formula but the thing is
franchise films those franchises like
Star Wars that make a name popular it
became popular because they were trying
something new they're trying something
inventive when they hit mass audiences
people were floored by them and every
wouldn't saw them you know takes
something special to get millions of
people to go watch it
but once millions of people are watching
it no one's gonna mess with the formula
if I went to go make a Star Wars movie
now they would never let me do that kind
of experimentation they would never let
me try to be as original as his first
Star Wars movies I mean look at them now
look at what JJ Able's did was at the
Star Wars The Force awakens they didn't
let him try anything special it was the
same formula rehashed again
new visuals it's kind of disappointing
you know I was kind of thinking the same
thing with video game movies like I feel
like Sam and I are the first ones who
could make a good video game movie we
tried with rush and in the process we
learned to make a video game movie
requires the video game company to give
you utmost trust with their concept to
be original with it to try something new
and fresh and grab people's attention
and once again that's an established
multi-million dollar franchise they are
not gonna let you try anything special
everything that must get approved
everything needs to go through the mill
all those sharp edges that might hurt
somebody and offend them they're gonna
get sanded down but those sharp edges I
want to get people to talk about the
stuff in the first place so it's a
little depressing but at the same time
it's a good reason to try doing original
things and in fact if you look at the
YouTube channel this year that's what
we've been doing any twenty you know
what with all the projects that come in
and out of this studio things do get a
little bit messy with junk and clutter
being left around the studio in places
where it shouldn't be so today I'm very
clean it needs to happen every few
months and today's the day we get about
a week of cleanliness and it's kind of
hit but you know there are more
important things in the world you can
always tell where someone's been because
everyone who leaves little dropping
piles it's like oh there's a famous
scent must have been there
speaking of piles give me that we're Sam
and Nico Nico still cleaning Nico still
going I'm so going
don't throw away knowledge yeah if
you're gonna throw away a book just give
it to me because I have a library at my
house I don't know now I have a library
like with real books at my house yeah
it's like internet without what that's
don't I have all the world's knowledge
find in the encyclopedia internet all
sorts of things would come off by then
no Jurassic Park
I'm glad yeah me too hive is actually no
I was just being becoming alive around
that year so it's about I'm glad you
were dead then yeah I was dead in the
[Music]
[Music]
eye stay frosty with and I we got Samuel
Yates Richard Linder Robin the dinosaur
and Sean Witt no be calm
so Hawk lie aka slugs he wrote James
Bailey Brian ant ojek Richard Blackburn
yeah thank you guys very much if you're
interested supporting these videos
[Music]
[Music]
was the last movie that came out that
actually got you super excited and you
were rewarded for that excitement Mad
Max fury road and Mad Max fury road it
does not have a story or structure this
anywhere the same to any other film that
came out within years of that movie it
was a new movie you look at films now
you look at why people aren't excited
about movies it's all the same thing so
my opinion these days the two best
directors in Hollywood they work
together Phil Lord and Chris Miller they
did the lego movie 22 Jump Street Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs really funny
guys really good storytellers and they
were making the Han Solo and Lando movie
and Donald Glover played Lando
Calrissian I don't know what's playing
Han Solo some other guy those two genius
directors with Don Glover as Lando what
a combination
of course too unpredictable
too much creative energy in one space
too many row guard is doing their own
thing the producers shut it down they
fired the directors because of creative
differences in other words they want to
do something special
producer want to go buy the books and
make some money Star Wars known for
taking risks weird risks sometimes aka
the prequels but risks nonetheless it's
no longer risky franchise no longer
original don't go to the theaters
expecting to see something new when you
go see style how many how many directors
did the second doesn't matter it doesn't
matter who the director as the Star Wars
is because people directing Star Wars
are the producers they are going by the
books by the numbers to make the movie
that they know will sell their focus
testing the heck out of it
reading it as necessary reshooting
scenes is necessary aka road one to make
a movie that will sell there's no
message there's nothing unique there's
only storytelling there's no risks and
if I were to make a Star Wars movie
those are the things I'd want to do I'd
want to do new visuals no one has ever
seen before I want to do new stories no
one has ever seen before new aliens new
planets
I want to go crazy with it but no it's
changed my filmmaking if you look at the
cargo channel we do a lot of videos are
based on other IPs the interesting
experiments weird twists on them things
that we would like and we can get away
with it because we shouldn't get
permission to do it because they're
basically in the fan film genre we kind
of fought back every other one video
based on an IP that I exist like a video
game and then one video that's
completely original this year's been
different if we're going to be
successful filmmakers if we're gonna
make movies we want to make it's not
gonna be based on someone else's
franchise no company's gonna give us the
keys to their kingdom that's why I think
Hollywood's dying that's what people
aren't excited about going
movies anymore because it's all the same
story over and over again this is a box
from the New York Toronto Film Festival
speaking of which we make another film
or drone videos John Film Festival no is
the New Zealand drunk we got a Lexar
card reader
wait that's not that's a lightning cable
[Music]
micro SD card we got a 32 gigabyte card
also right here it's so much memory how
Michael get your dirty hands off my
memory there modulars you can stack them
together will really come in handy out
of all the things we use somebody
sending us a box full of micro SD the
reader is like the most useful thing do
you think we'll use these as much as the
drones we want in previous years I will
use these more we did throw money by the
way that that was your guys's fault I
did not take any of those cards by the
way this man who sells a GoPro on his
desk oh no it's in my pocket right now
inside here is is no one just to know
it's an island
yeah we're gonna be live-streaming an
archery video growing for an iPhone on
the target they're going to shoot at the
iPhone well not directly out we're gonna
shoot around it we are going to
livestream from the perspective of the
phone on the target it's William Taylor
for the 21st century because we're still
using an apple it's going to be really
intense not quite sure when we're going
to do it is either gonna go on our
Facebook page or Instagram so you're
gonna fall both we haven't decided yet
so you need to follow us on Facebook
it's with the Calm Lord or digital or
you follow us on instagram at corridor
digital we'll announce it so just pay
attention it's gonna be really intense
it's Nick's iPhone
[Music]